people of the internet
hello and welcome in to Retro raconteur
live we are here today with the Legend
of Zelda
tears of the Kingdom Rossi my man first
in the chat
it's incredible Ross it's really
incredible
Rossi thank you so much for being here
Mike and
Mike my condition welcome in how's it
going Christy very close Christy very
very close
third for Christy and look at that not
even a countdown that's really
impressive that you guys were that's
real that's really impressive I I posted
the go live see on YouTube it's a little
bit different because you have to
get all the thumbnail and all that stuff
set up when you go live versus something
like twitch where you know you just pick
go live and you're good to go but yes we
are here live it has been quite some
time
since we have played The Legend of Zelda
tears of the Kingdom on stream or we've
been posting the Let's Plays regularly
over on our let's play Channel
however
those are old for me they're old for me
I've done a lot
of extra stuff I've been going around
doing shrines been upgrading my stamina
been upgrading my hearts
but I have not yet progressed the story
I wanted to save that for you guys for
the live stream for the let's play so
that's where we're at
stream elements bot is running let's go
I'm hoping the stream elements bot is
working correctly I tried to switch
everything over from nightbot the other
day so we got Dylan in the house as well
Dylan if you don't mind Dylan or Christy
one of the mods in here just try like
try like an exclamation point Discord or
something let's see if
if our stream elements bot is working
correctly
I think it is but I want to be sure
two lies in one week we are spoiled
yes stream elements it's working nice
nice nice all right so yeah we got to
get right into the gameplay because we
have another live stream
actually you're getting you're getting
two in two in a second day Dylan two and
two in one day because we're going
immediately from this over into uh the
live stream with expecto go so it's
gonna be myself James Andy reloads
wizard PhD and Benjamin Stowe we're
gonna be joining I'm sure Hogwarts
Legacy will be and and Harry Potter will
be a topic of discussion but really
we're focusing on games that we've been
playing
that we've enjoyed and what we're
looking forward to
all right so I'm gonna go ahead and
switch it over
all right check check check one two one
two
oh yeah and I need to start recording
too because we will I will post this
over on the let's play Channel and kind
of cut it up and everything
later on but
all right
but yeah thank you guys for being here
hope everyone is having a great Thursday
afternoon
Thursday morning Thursday evening
depending on where you're at in the
world so we are ready to do the wind
Temple though
um but as you can see I have ran into
I've ran into a little enemy here so
we're gonna try and take him out first
so let's just go ahead and try this
right here
and I guess you know what I think I've
already I must have already done this
because the enemies are
the enemies are gone that are usually on
top of him
all right we're gonna go ahead and try
to slide away here
because he's gonna throw us off anyway
all right and then let's use what I've
been trying to do is like I'm trying to
like get right oh no well okay there we
go great start man great start I think I
only had three hearts I think that might
be that might be what's going on there
Paula welcome in how's it going Paula
and also Anna here as well Anna good to
see you welcome in welcome in
your eyes are working oh yeah see we
only have three hearts
yeah what I've been trying to do is if
you if you get underneath these guys
you can use a sin but you see how it
doesn't work everywhere you have to get
it like just the right angle oh come on
come on come on come on I saw it green
for a moment
there we go
it's taking a long time to okay
and now you're just
excuse me
he just immediately throws me off oh my
gosh
you know what maybe we'll just leave
this guy alone maybe maybe we'll just
leave him maybe we'll just maybe we'll
just leave him and go
dude that was too funny
all right you know what we got a new
strategy for him this time
[Music]
the battle Talus is the name of this guy
so yeah I this is like the only game
I've been playing on my switch so I
guess the last time I played I was in
the middle of fighting this guy
all right so this is gonna give
and you know what let's just go ahead
that actually did quite a bit of damage
let's immediately do another one
and try to fly over
all right let's get a bunch of hits in
right here oh dude you can see the arrow
okay hold on hold on let's switch to
something like
ooh black horrible and Hammer
there we go one more hit nice
good night sir
it has been a long time indeed
how you been doing Anna are you still
traveling about the world
Paula how about you things going well
for you
I know you guys are in uh
slightly different time zones so when we
do those late night lives we were live
here on YouTube Tuesday night we saw
Anna for just a bit very very briefly
all right what should I fuse this guy to
here
I'm really not sure like these things
right here
I'm pretty sure they're
I think I have one already let's see oh
it was the one that just broke wasn't it
Okay so we've used one to that right
there the stone Talus Sledge put it up
to 19.
we could do this that's actually the
only thing I even have the option to do
right now
spiked iron ball hammer
spiked iron ball Hammer it's just like a
stick though I think
I mean I hate to leave it here but
I guess we could just go ahead and do
put it on the broadsword here
go ahead and fuse it to the Broad Sword
you finally got home yesterday back to
reality no way so how many places did
you go where all were you traveling
oh my goodness what is this over here
do you guys see that there was something
like really
shining and and like a cloud of
but it went it went behind right there
could be one of the Dragons or the gliox
IDE okay all right so I promise win
Temple gameplay
let's get into some wind Temple gameplay
here's what we need to do we need to go
here
I think this is going to be our closest
spot to it is this Shrine right here
Cloud Roth how's it going Cloud Roth
welcome
uh yeah right we were looking at the
clouds Dylan and Cloud Roth appears you
love to see it
Paulie the late night streams are fine
you have insomnia oh no you don't sleep
properly I've been getting into some bad
habits again guys I really have
I was doing really good with the sleep
but
I don't know these past few weeks I've
been I've been slipping back
into my old ways I'm just a night out I
mean I just I just am I think it's too
hard to change
all right so this is the regional
phenomenon we're investigating right
here this is uh
ebra in the Northwest which is where
we're at so I'm gonna go ahead and Mark
that
and let's see if it appears on our
wait not that map
this map
okay so is that where it's wanting me to
go now see it's been so long man it's
it's gonna take me a while
to get back to where where we were
supposed to be
all right so I'm just gonna I don't
think we're supposed to go to the Rito
Village though
yeah I think we've already
I think we've already done that
this one this is what I'm supposed to do
right here Tulum was not at the cave
when you went out to find him
gassane told you that he left Hebrew
South Summit cave and went toward the
lone Cedar Tree on Toronto Peak visible
to the north
according to whoops according to gassane
he saw a group of monster yes okay that
is where I'm trying to get to
so yeah I thought it was a completely
different direction
right over here so let's just go ahead
and Mark that
let's see do I need to go yeah a little
bit we'll mark it with the red that way
it shows up whenever we do
this right here but it's kind of hard to
see because of there we go it's gonna
say it's hard to see because of all the
mountains in the area
yo James what's up dude welcome in
how's your day going so far getting
ready for the big live stream later on
it's been so long since I've played this
game you guys you can I mean you can
tell we're pretty Rusty
you can definitely tell
all right so this might be it right here
now how do I get food
what a disaster I came all this way to
scrounge mushrooms and now this I'll
never get to the Deep parts of the cave
with a messed up Wing chill shrooms grow
all over this cave so I figured it'd be
a prime spot for Scavenging a little
food cold water is built up here now and
I can't pick any chill shrooms without
Crossing it
or nearly my wings would take me right
over but I hurt my wing in a small scrap
of Monsters uh okay
bring back chill streams I mean I can I
can give you some dude he needs 10 of
them
and that was a side quest that was that
wasn't even
wasn't where we supposed to be Gabriella
here as well how's it going Gabriella
welcome in
you bought it but haven't played it yet
and well I mean you've kind of you've
got I was about to say you've got an
excuse you've been traveling but it is
the switch which is is the console
that's perfect for traveling dude this
guy didn't even try all he had to do was
walk in and there were two right there
wait three he could have gotten three
all right let's see are we gonna need to
use some Ultra hand here
oh that's pretty far away
I don't think we can swim through this
either
and then let's see if we try to climb
the ice that's not gonna work
what happens if we do if we shoot like
like a fire and it's just gonna go out
we need a way to like
give us some sort of uh
something we can cross with
I wonder what these things do up here
like let's see if I fuse
let's sort that yeah the fire fruit I'm
glad they give you a lot of those
all right so that's gonna melt
oh man
it doesn't melt enough
like can I get that to fall in the water
darn it I was hoping it would give me
like a little iceberg that I could cross
with ah you didn't take your switch okay
I got you I gotcha
jumping to old stool welcome welcome to
the stream how's it going
not live at two and I know I know
you've only been here for yeah because
we usually do whenever we stream on
YouTube there are typically
late late night stream so
thought about thought it's about time to
try to get in some some afternoon
streams over here we've been streaming a
lot on Twitch but I know not all of you
are are over there on Twitch as well so
try to try to balance it out a little
bit more
oh you didn't take your switch Anna okay
well that then yeah I mean you got an
excuse you've been traveling the world
dude why
okay maybe recall
like was that over here a long time ago
no
Ultra hand I mean we could we could
always make something outside
and then come back
and we could let's see would a send help
us at all
I don't think so all right let's just
see what happens here
oh it goes too quick
I think if we if we maxed out our hearts
though I think we might be able to make
it
if we maxed out our hearts I think so
perfect hour perfect way to finish the
last hour of your work day nice
last hour
you must do you work uh you must work
like a different kind of
not a normal nine to five type of shift
cloud or are you in a different wait
wait can I just pick these up again
is that gonna give us 10 or did it reset
probably reset yeah because we only have
no wait it didn't reset
I think we just keep dying
all right what happens let's see if we
if we climb this yeah you slide down
[Music]
all right he was talking about having
wings and flying over I mean what if we
do this what if we
what if we light this on fire
I was hoping it would give me the
Mrs raconteur welcome in
I was hoping we could
no I didn't want to fuse that
oh man you can see it's been the
controls they're Rusty man oh wait I
need to put do I need to put that away
yeah I was like wait why is the drop not
there
okay now let's just shoot this with
mega fire
why does that not work oh we need
we need the wood beside it too
oh you're on Eastern time okay Cloud
gotcha starting at six A.M
oh man early early
all right let's hold
oh my gosh you guys there's so many
controls in this game
so many controls
okay
add now just drop you okay now we need
to
drop our Flint again
but we need our Flint to be a little bit
closer to this right see what I'm going
to try to do is get enough of a
draft that I can just fly over with my
glider
okay now
there we go
no I want to put you put that out
no how do you get it to do the
oh my gosh you guys this is bad
how do you get to do the thing
where it goes up really quick
well we got a fire created
we can maybe we should just sit here and
rest
oh my Ryan what's up Ryan welcome in
I thought you were I thought you were in
England Paula I thought I remembered
that
yeah I think you need we need something
bigger than just the wood like this
oh I need pine cones okay
that's right
thank you silly nugs thank you
appreciate it
all right so I don't want to drop it
though
we want to throw it
oh my gosh
okay
here we go yes
let's go silly nugs for the win
dude
see that's why I hate taking big breaks
between when you're playing a really big
game like this
because this game I mean I love it but
there are there are a lot of controls
a lot of controls a lot of mechanics to
remember
all right well we definitely have enough
chill streams for this guy now
let's go with the oh man we really need
something
oh we really don't have anything that's
good for mining I guess that wasn't bad
appreciate it yes
you guys can tell I literally just fired
the game up
just fired the game up
zodiac you've had a Hiatus from playing
as well
I just had a lot of other things going
on we were traveling and had some other
stuff
making a lot of videos
okay
now if I just use recall on that it's
only going to bring it back here
actually know what you know what you
know what that might not be bad
let's just get it right in the middle
there
dude there's got there's I guarantee
there's a way to do this that was much
much easier
I guarantee
but I think we're gonna be able to make
this work
we're gonna take some hits right here
you're bad too but you still enjoy it
okay come on swim quickly quickly
quickly
yes
Ellen you didn't get notified
did it not post in the Discord I mean we
did I haven't went I've never went live
that quickly on YouTube like between
posting and actually going live so maybe
there's something weird with that
Perhaps Perhaps
cold resistance sure why not
let's eat that one
and then let's see do we have something
small here that we can
just like one or two that's for an
attack up
we'll do the little meat skewer right
there
all right so now let's go on
let's give this guy his chill shrooms
and then we need to go find the wind
Temple
came to this cave together oh yeah I got
you I got you Verla
and Anna that's uh the thing about the
sound alerts that's a YouTube thing they
they do not have that
on YouTube
you didn't actually cross the pond and
pick the children's rooms did you that's
exactly what we did you weren't worried
about falling into the freezing water
I mean we we did have a few uh a few
situations there but we made it we made
it through
I can't just take them for free though
here why don't I give you this purple
rupee hey 50 rupees
[Music]
oh you know this isn't the only cave in
these mountains with pools of freezing
water be careful where you explore yeah
I'm pretty sure there was a better way
to do that oh
dude I bet we were supposed to use this
right here
we could have taken that in there
we could have 100 taken that in there
oh yeah uh Gabriella I haven't played it
but I know I know Elwyn play has played
a lot of Diablo and I think
did Christy play that one too I can't
remember
okay no no no I think it is right in
oh we can't see the we can't even see
the beam of light you know what let's go
back in here and let's use ascend
see if we can get all the way on top of
this
there we go right there
come on take us up really high so we can
get get back to this this dungeon
oh I need to set an alarm so I'll be
ready for the next live stream we're
gonna be uh
oh wait is it putting me on the side
what
sort of
oh yeah I remember this I remember this
oh we're in the right spot let's go
let's go let's go
yes
all right let's go ahead and remove that
PIN
all right let me look at our
Adventure log I want to see exactly what
it says
uh he left Hebrew South Summit went
toward the lone cedar tree onto lonto
Peak visible to the north you saw a
group of monsters and gave Chase alone
okay
let's go ahead and grab these
ah she decided not to play it okay
Dustin Mills
wait
wait what has YouTube YouTube's been
doing something weird with the names
lately guys
Dustin Mills that is Dustin Quist right
or is that you're like no dude I have no
idea who that is
oh you got a different account okay
gotcha so it is actually you though gosh
but no it's not just you I mean I guess
you actually have a different account
but I've also been seeing a lot of uh
YouTube's been doing this thing lately
where
it shows There When people's name when
they comment it's like at and whatever
their full username is
strange
Dusty technical wait wait wait wait wait
okay this is a different this is a
different Dustin this is our radiant
gaming Dusty right right
we have another uh we have a Dustin
Dusty
who is a
a regular here on the streams
come on
and I was like wait I know I know what
Dustin Mills too
oh it's all good dude
that's too funny though that is too
funny all right so I know Dusty uh
you've beaten this right
man I'm so far behind
I've been playing a little bit off
stream and off of our
off of our let's play series but I've
only been doing like going around and
doing shrines and stuff so I haven't
even done the first temple here which is
what we're getting ready to
I think we're getting ready to tackle it
all right that is not the way we're
supposed to go I think we're supposed to
just follow this little path over here
you haven't beaten it no way
I mean it's not really a game that I
would want to end I feel like
all right so we already helped our buddy
right here
president Hudson gotta support gotta
support
all right so where
up here actually are we supposed to
climb this
right
all right let's go again
yeah I think we can afford to do the
little jumps right there
dude
where is it marking
okay we're apparently right on the
marker oh there's more
oh it's a big boy
you don't know if you're even a gamer at
this point oh it's all good you're a
gamer
you're a gamer I've been thinking about
making a video uh somehow about trying
to tackle my video game backlog
because dude 2023 has been just an
absolutely incredible year for games and
I already had a really big backlog of
some of the best games ever made that I
haven't I haven't been able to play yet
but this one I mean this is like number
one on my list like I I have to beat
this before starting anything else I
just have to
okay wait are we supposed to follow
these guys you think they'll tell us
where we need to go
all right we gotta take them out
all right we're gonna go straight for
the big boy
wait did it not fuse oh it did
okay now let's go for oh man I feel like
uh I don't have a bomb Arrow right now
oh a bomb Arrow would be perfect
right in the middle of these guys
all right let's go one more fire arrow
thank you
there we go
man it is crazy how in this game if you
if you start off a fight really strong
it can go so much differently if you
like if we had just landed and tried to
take those guys head on
I feel like it would have been much
worse
Dylan's like uh I wasn't timed out
I wasn't timed out what I don't see a
timeout message either
oh my gosh who is this where did you
come from
ah
you served me well
let's go with the topaz Rod I feel like
these last a long time
[Music]
yeah this one's gonna take him out
pretty quick come on come on come on
[Music]
did we launch him off
all right so we've taken out all the
enemies in this area
but I have no idea where to go this one
had a question mark on it oh boomerang
a decayed wooden boomerang I can't
believe we haven't found one of these
yet a useful tool that comes back after
you throw its current state has not
lessened its performance
obviously they were they were there
there was a mistake
it could be since we switched it over to
uh to stream elements
there might be some kind of protection
that's turned on by default that I
haven't
whoa whoa whoa wait do we have two
dylans now or
somehow Dylan just lose his mod status
what the heck
wait do we have somebody posing is Dylan
now we have two dylans what is going on
what is happening
yeah what is happening
is this some elaborate prank
oh my gosh come on man
that's gonna take forever using
using fire arrows
uh let's equip this one
this is a black oh my gosh don't get me
started on Black Mirror Anna have you
been anybody watch Black Mirror in here
dude
all right one more time
what the heck
okay you watched Jonah's awful today
all right that one
is
I want to be I don't want to give away
too much
but let's just say after watching
episodes two and three Anna
I am just
like I need a hug
I need lots of hugs
I mean black mirror is always pretty
dark right it always has these dark
twists but
whoo
prepare yourself prepare yourself Anna
before you watch episode two
you gotta get in the right frame of mind
for that one
just just just make sure you're ready
for it
and then episode three
I'm trying to think of a word I can say
that won't get haunting haunting both of
them are just downright haunting
with their their twist here he is oh my
gosh we found him
freaking finally
all right before we do that yeah should
be good
all right toolin
stupid monster
huh
rotten monster took my good bow we just
had one of our good bows break
trying to find you trying to get up here
and locate you
oh we got this Tulum we got this
we got just the item for it did you know
I can blow a strong gust of wind
anywhere I feel like I'll do it for you
too that way you can glide over to where
that monster went just tell me where to
point the gust and I'll make it for you
tulin's power of wind when Tulane's Aura
is charged he can create a stream of
wind that blows straight forward this
can be used for bursts of speed while
paragliding dude that is awesome
all right so I just need to talk to him
and then like kind of aim it
whoa
I don't think that I don't think I don't
think we did it right oh but he's still
following me
he is still following me
all right let's do the keys Fireball
got him
I owe you big time link without you my
bow might have been lost for good dude
that ability though that's gonna come in
that's gonna be very clutch
even though I used it completely
incorrectly right there we just kind of
fell off the side
flying behind me that's cool
so you can get even more distance
they're not gonna make a fool out of me
twice let's get them together oh let's
do it
oh
[Music]
man we won hit that first one
well that was quick we did it
hey look I think this might have been a
hideout for those monsters
whoa what is that
hoy
have the Imposter accounts left I think
it was I I think it was Elwyn and Dylan
just messing around because it started
doing it with L one too
that was some impressive teamwork you
two
I didn't listen when gassane tried to
stop me I thought I could handle it I
just ended up losing my favorite bow to
those stupid things
hmm
dang I bet now you see why we were
treating you like a small chick
wow
[Music]
I think I finally get what dad has been
trying to tell me all this time
is that all there is to the story
seems unlike you to let your bow be
taken toolin
what
I guess she was fine because then she
zoomed up above that cloud
where's the Zelda flew above the cloud
how can that be
we're not going to get to the bottom of
it sitting around here toolin link came
out here looking for Princess Zelda
should go with him and investigate the
cloud you say the princess sword into
I'm thinking hoping that's the wind
Temple since we have that in our
thumbnail
that we're starting the wind Temple
today
I want to see for myself as soon as I
can but the strong winds make any
approach from the sides impossible the
only way in is through the top
but
there's not a Rito alive capable of
crossing the stormy sky and making it
all the way there except for one
talking about you toolin what
only you have the skill and training to
create gusts at will Tulum will be the
finest reader Warrior of all once he
understands the value of working with
his allies
oh my
ah you know who said that to me your old
dad Tiba
oh
let's do it
I saw Princess Zelda up on the sky
islands near Hebrew Peak let's check
there first
wait I thought you were
hold on
no I'm not I'm not ready for how do I
like I want to cancel the gust there we
go
cancel
[Music]
all right Falcon bow
okay
go ahead and pick that up we can always
fuse it with something else
all right where does he want me to go
he said go with tool into the sky
islands above Heber Peak where he claims
he saw Princess Zelda
oh my goodness way over here
okay so I bet we're supposed to go this
way
wait how do I okay I talk to you
wait why is it not working
maybe I'm just supposed to run and okay
let's try this again
there we go
I think it's better if you kind of start
off gliding a little bit first
all right let's look that way
foreign
whoa didn't even know this was here
I'll take it
a zoonite sword oh man it's just a level
six though really
oh the dude that's that is clutch right
there
gonna use that ability a lot
all right let's see if we can do like an
Ascend right here
yes let's go
yeah Dylan it totally would have
it's probably they probably mean for you
to do that after you get that ability
all right this has got to be the way
we're supposed to go
oh man look at all these ruins right
here oh look at all those guys
all right can we just completely
yeah yeah we're just gonna completely
bypass you guys
completely bypass you guys not even
fight you
Dylan's a Gryffindor prankster like a
Fred and George
are you calling Dylan a Fred and George
can't carry any more of those hey we'll
take some arrows though
all right Ascend I don't think we're
gonna be able to use
a sin that was really close
I think we've got enough to climb up
here
oh yeah we should be good we can
actually probably even
Jump Ahead
all right there we go
definitely a sin right here
you accept that role
oh man they're gonna start they're gonna
start throwing those ass
we're gonna start rolling them down this
hill
oh man the Homing capability on these
I didn't know how far it would it would
track but
they were pretty high up there and it
still worked
what do we have here
another chill shroom
you're a chaotic good Hufflepuff Paula
I can see that I could see that
Puck says if only it were possible to
find out what's inside of this blizzard
oh we're going Huck we're going right in
there
if it isn't tool and I was too focused
on the cloud to notice you
oh
something told me you were the best one
for this mission
the wind gusts technique since you first
demonstrated it
oh here we go dude here we go
between link and me you won't be
disappointed all right
okay
now what are we supposed to do here can
Ascend reach that far
oh no I didn't think it could
hold on
no wrong wrong button
definitely the wrong button
okay now can it reach
oh come on
yes we got it
I was thinking there's got to be a
reason for these blocks right here
oh man I kind of want to explore what's
oh dude if we oh we haven't unlocked
that Tower yet
it'd be so easy to just fly down to that
Tower right now but
it'd be very difficult to get back up
here so I'm not gonna do it
now what
look
all right
there we go
talks Paula says she's Tonks mixed with
social awkwardness of Newt scamander oh
my goodness
Rising island chain in the Hebrew
mountain sky
I didn't mean to do that but
it was around here that I saw Princess
Zelda now I don't know where she could
have gone
no way you see her again
no no no we don't want to go to the ship
yet just let me see what's up here
okay nothing's up there
all right tooling fine we'll go
investigate the ship now
doing that thing again
it's doing the thing
excuse me
where
who is that
yeah that's what I'm saying whose voice
was that was it coming from somewhere up
there
you heard it too
you see that thing inside the cloud
is that another boat but it's huge
oh my gosh look at all of them
like
God ascended to Heaven leaving behind an
ark
this whole thing is just like the song
of the Stormwind Arc oh
[Music]
nowhere to go but up
let's do it
oh my gosh what how about a warning
toolin I did not know that was gonna
happen
oh man
we definitely need to no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
definitely need to do this just so we'll
have a point to fast travel too way to
get up here really quick
let's go ahead and skip the cut scene
though
wait so does tooling go in
let's see does he go into the shrine
with us
because that could be a very useful
ability when you're inside a shrine
no way right yeah
by ourselves in here downward Force
wait
um excuse me
maybe we can't do this yeah
yeah all right this is really confusing
I've never seen a shrine like this
Timothy ninja welcome in how's it going
dude
hope you're having a good Thursday so
far
yeah I'm I guess we can't do this yet
what did it say downward Force like
maybe we need to
all right that's very bizarre we'll come
back to that one maybe we have to maybe
it's something that we unlock
at the wind Temple I don't know
try to shoot an arrow with the orange
thing oh we could try that
I don't think I saw an orange thing but
let me go back
yeah cause the shrines you can do
anytime that's not how they they don't
set up the shrines where you need a
specific item you you pretty much have
everything you need
oh yeah I see it now we might be able to
just we might even be able to hit that
through
what if you didn't have an arrow though
there we go
yo shout out to cosmetic
coming in clutch yeah if you're exactly
if you're out of arrows
then it would be problematic
I'm just so anxious to get in and try
the oh we missed the Precision shot I'm
just so anxious to get into the first
first temple that
I was like eh
okay we have another one here
okay wait where are we trying to Launch
oh this way this way this way
oh this is kind of cool
this is really cool I'm glad we did this
all right there's always a special
hidden chest the question is where is it
in this one
uh
not seeing anything
oh wait we have to jump on it don't we
maybe it's over here somewhere
nope
I think this is the end right here
whoa
all right we've gotta unlock it somehow
so we're probably looking for another
oh that was
that was actually really close oh I see
what we're looking for I see it
oh man
oh yikes
nice we got it
[Music]
you could throw something in that
situation but you can't later in the
yeah right there
oh if you were out of arrows that'd be
so annoying
okay wait
that's the end of it right there so
where is
there's always a chest somewhere
in here somewhere
oh hey there's our Arrow
who's that
I wonder where it is in this one
oh wait I see a ladder right there
dude this is so fun
I guess the ladder is just to climb out
of there
because I think all of them have an
extra chest don't they there's never
anything good in them but I always want
to get it just just to say I can check
it off the list you know
see how many of these do we have now oh
restarting okay we're at one
hey John plays welcome in
thank you for the follow I just realized
I need to move that
for the uh thank you for subscribing to
the channel
let's move
I think I just need to move that up a
little bit next time it should be just
above my head
all right fully
fully healed there on our hearts
now we should be ready to continue
up to the temple what's gonna happen is
we're gonna get we're gonna reach the
temple right when it's time for us to
hop off
I got just just under an hour before I
get a switch over
and we'll be going live over on expecto
goes Channel
oh man I feel a sneeze coming I feel a
sneeze coming you guys
it's one of those it's going to take a
minute though
good pick
about to say nothing there good there we
go
[Music]
Five Arrows I think we're doing pretty
pretty good on arrows right now yeah
we're at 138
.
yeah that Shrine see how see how that
one does not have the little treasure
beside it that one does
that's a little indicator that you uh
you did find the treasure and if you
don't see it then
you did not find the extra chest so
it's got to be somewhere when you're
when you're flying around in that big
area all right I don't think there's
anything else we need to do here
definitely gonna need the
special
gust technique right there
yeah this is my first one Timothy I I
went a long
had a long time without playing the game
or I should say without really
progressing the game I was playing but I
was just going around doing some shrines
and stuff trying to upgrade
let's switch to
push back to this one
oh dang
he's getting in on the fighting too
let's go
see a wooden stick all right so we're
maxed out on weapons right now
I didn't know if I'd be able to jump
above that or not
all right these things are fun man I
love this right here launch
let's go ahead and glide this way
this one has a cool boss fight let's go
dude I'm so excited
I'm so glad I can't well I don't want to
say anything because I I don't know a
lot about it so I'm going in pretty
pretty blind
oh yeah we need to drop
one of our bows that's not as good here
let's see
oh wow that one's only level four
drop you
and I'll drop you as well
pick up that one
and let's get the Zone I charge more
arrows
they're giving us an awful lot of arrows
I feel like arrows might be really
useful in this area
they all have great boss fights nice uh
that's what I want to hear man
that is what I want to hear
have you beaten the game Timothy are you
all all the way through it
let's see what we got here
all right we're gonna need Ascend but
probably just Out Of Reach
see what if we climb on top of you
oh I see we gotta move it back this way
I don't need to move it back this way
all right we're next
I feel like there's probably going to be
something valuable up here
oh man I wonder if we need to melt that
somehow
or is that just telling you you can't
you're not gonna be able to climb
that's probably what it is oh but you
could use Ascend all the way through
that's it dude that's it
nor zonai charges
you haven't beaten it you think you only
have one main story Quest left trying to
max out find armor nice
oh wait maybe we don't even have to I
was thinking we were gonna have to go
all the way down there but maybe
you don't actually even need to do that
maybe we can do it right from inside
here
oh this would be so nice
let's go
I haven't found a single piece of the
fierce deity set so are you trying like
you don't want to look up anything about
it you want to just try to find it on
your own
I respect it I respect it
oh okay this one's a little tricky
all right we're all the way at the top
now I don't see any way to go except
over to there
because if we go
see
We're not gonna be able to hit Ascend on
anything
over that way so yeah let's just do this
oh that's the way we're supposed to go I
see it now
oh
good anything up here to find no
Oh I thought we took him out
I did not think he was still up
Rusty broadsword yeah I think we already
maxed out on weapons
no
okay it worked out
yeah
it totally worked out
can we make it over there I don't think
we can I think we gotta settle for this
oh there's a way to launch out of this
right here we do not have any bombs
right now
I do know that
see if we can do this right here
no
no no no no no no no no
please no oh no
oh no okay well worst case scenario we
can yeah we're just gonna have to go to
that shrine
we can fast travel back to that shrine
and while we're at it
while we're at it
the only thing only things that you've
looked up are the amiibo items gotcha
couple the story areas
oh you wish you hadn't looked a hat and
looked it up
yeah I haven't looked up a lot either in
terms of uh
in terms no story stuff at all
I was I seen saw a few videos about the
whole item duplication thing that was in
there for a while before they patched it
out
what it's one of these
it fully stripped me of everything
oh boy
Proving Grounds
no Arrow
but he has one
okay let's do some fuse action now
oh no it's not what I meant to fuse
that is not what I meant to fuse
I want to fuse no I want to fuse this
yes
the spike thing let's go
[Music]
flurry Rush
yeah I really enjoy these too
can we turn off the siren please
[Music]
see did this guy drop yeah he did he
dropped some arrows over here
you have to equip it though
wait did he not drop I thought he had a
bow
there it is there it is there it is
oh it stopped
[Music]
oh that doesn't do anything okay
this might be the last one
[Music]
oh powerful
let's go
I can't believe I fell all the way to
oh that was bad
that was really tough tough situation
all right now we got all our stuff back
though let's go
and there's the chest right there so you
don't have to worry about getting
getting anywhere else in this one
[Music]
oh and a sapphire
no have not been to Terry town yet not
in this game
I did that whole questline in breath of
the wild though but I haven't been there
yet in this one
all right so that should bring us up to
two spirit orbs
cool stuff there nice
all right so now what we're gonna have
to do is we're gonna have to fast travel
back
to that Shrine that's that's higher up
the one that we completed
just so we don't have to go all the way
okay wait so it's gonna be considered in
a sky island yes there it is down with
force that was it
all right fast travel there
and then from here
I think we're still gonna have quite a
ways to go because this was about
well I don't know I don't know how high
up we have to get because we were
already pretty high up there
all right so let's see if we go here
all right I'm trying to remember which
way we went from here oh yeah we went
this way
actually we might be able to make that
with the gust
s yeah we're good
I wish he had something that if you were
falling he could launch you back up a
little bit
that'd be kind of cool
I'm totally gonna have to change this
thumbnail later I thought I was ready I
thought I was literally about to start
the wind Temple no
not so fast
a lot more we had to do to get there
first
all right now we're we're making our way
now making our way now
okay yeah then we have to go over there
use the sin to go through that and then
we'll just about be caught up to where
we were
oh man this moved on us we're gonna move
that again huh
what's up
all right then we're going to ascend
go through
then back over here
yeah I guess that middle part right
there is kind of just like
or that bottom part is to help you out
if you
somehow don't make it through right here
all right Ascend back to the top
oh
there we go
almost there
oh my gosh what is that down there
one of those guys
I have fought I think two of them
because you can go back and you can
fight them again
I believe
so I think there's one that I've done
twice it's one of those guys
you guys know them right
oh wait I didn't even go over there that
the first time
hmm
I'm like should I go fight him or should
I just launch up with this again
let's go fight him we're probably not
gonna get any closer to him than we are
right now
oh it broke no
not a good time to break
let's go with something a little bit
oh the he knocks Hammer might be pretty
good
foreign
helping out here let's go
we didn't have a lot of time
no I missed him
yikes I did a lot of damage
oh my gosh
no I don't want to climb you
oh I wonder if you can use uh
oh you totally can
nice tool in helping out big time right
there
I want a different weapon
I need something faster
oh one hit let's go
that is just what we needed
yeah he had some well-timed shots right
there
that is for sure no but now you're
blowing away our stuff dude what are you
doing
don't do it
I haven't used those time bombs at all
yet
all right see what's in here
[Music]
an old map a very old map shows a marked
spot what could be there
another one in the depths that's three
now we've got marked
all right let's go ahead and uh let's
see we might as well fuse this to
something
zonite sword
I think this one might already have oh
no it doesn't nice
okay now we have to
start progressing back up I wonder if
there's anything over here that can
launch us
nope but I see somewhere we can use
ascend
flux constructs
was that a let me Google that for you
moment right there Dylan
okay
so this is about where we were earlier
and I don't have any bombs right now I
can't destroy that nope
[Music]
so I think this is going to be our best
way to do it
to get over here
oh man hold on though we've gotta we've
gotta get through there somehow
because I don't think I can use
let's see we'll Ascend reach right here
probably not
oh it's really close though
no what in the world
oh that's just wrong
that is just wrong right there
all right let's see if we do this
if we move you over just a wee bit
I still don't think it's it's enough
yes it is
let's go
all right now
dude where was that other spot there was
another spot where I oh right here yes
this is what we need to do but I just
need to make sure I'm perfectly over it
like that right there
let me throw
Yes we made it
[Music]
more arrows
getting so many arrows here
and I think you can get arrows inside
these too
yep
all right another Ascend coming up
coming up
oh great
one more dude tooling again
so clutch right there
all right
now
oh man can we make it that far
dude we still have so far to go look at
this
I don't know if we can make it that far
with him
I feel like we need to use that to
launch us again
because I don't see where we're supposed
to go this way I feel like it's got to
be in this direction
oh my gosh look at all this
all right here we go
come on come on come on come on come on
come on
yes
just made it let's go
all right
okay we're gonna be very careful this
time we're gonna land right in the
middle
it's exactly why very very important
there
all right I don't even want to risk
these guys
taking me out so
yeah see look here comes the other one
all right make sure we're centered over
it
oh I just realized it resets your
stamina too
the second that you bounce on one oh
that's big time right there that is big
time
Gabriella Sunrise hey thank you so much
Gabriella
with the 25 r-o-n
I'm not sure what currency that is but
thank you so much for the Super Chat
appreciate it
here's to more streams at this time
let's go
uh Gabriella do you do uh are you on
Twitch at all I'm trying to remember if
I've seen you when we stream over there
are you more you more just stick to
YouTube
oh okay I feel like they want us to cook
right here
I feel like the game is telling you hey
you need to cook
or maybe it's just giving you away if
you
make it all the way up here
oh did we actually hit that one nice
[Music]
a chill fin trout you're not on Twitch
okay I didn't yeah I didn't think I'd
remembered seeing you over there
beating the temple we're trying to reach
it Paula it's it's somewhere in there
I think
imagine if it was like a giant misdirect
wait I don't want to sit can I not cook
oh yeah we have to you have to hold it
first
okay let's cook some of those fish that
we just grabbed right there
all right so hold let's do two of them
and you know what let's throw a carrot
in there too and maybe
like an herb
laughs
oh my goodness that is big time right
there fried Wild Greens a basic
vegetable dish made by sauteing fresh
wild plants wait what what about my fish
we'll do two fish this time and one herb
let's see how that ends up
you're not allowed to say anything until
you play Anna you will see
you too will see how uh
how the game just grabs your attention
but hey I'm actually I'm I'm doing the
thing you know I'm not getting
sidetracked here
I'm not doing the thing I should say
we're we're making our way there
all right let's see what else do we want
to cook maybe some Hylian Tomatoes let's
do two of those
and we'll do one herb again
you can make pizza I saw I did see a
tweet about that
steamed Tomatoes let's go
oh you haven't done any of the Hogwarts
drops Gabriella
I hope they bring them back maybe they
will when the switch version comes out
sound alerts you can play
see this like tomatoes and tree nuts I
think that'd be good together probably
ah let's just try it
let's just see what happens you can't
carry any more meals excuse me I didn't
even know that was a thing
no way we're maxed out on meals
I guess it's a good thing right
that that means we are fully ready to do
this
I know Anna I'm just I'm just giving you
a hard time
everybody always everybody always likes
to
poke fun
at the player for whatever reason you
know I don't know why
I can't imagine why
okay that's where we just were although
we did not go all the way to the top
all right these guys we want to take
them out first
by the way uh let's see who was that
welcome to the channel Alice Alice thank
you so much for subscribing hope you're
having a good day so far
yeah guys if you were here hanging out
for the first time make sure you
subscribe to our Channel we are on
YouTube so the subscriptions are free
and we also post a lot of gaming videos
here on the channel which you might be
interested in
some uh some tears of the Kingdom
related dude that did a lot of damage
all right hold on I think I think we
need to eat right now I don't want to
take my chances on this let's just do
yeah let's do two of these
well I didn't switch weapons that's why
yeah this is not
you okay Tula doing all the work right
now man look at him
yeah use your own Parts against you
right there
okay toolin
I gotta say strong companion material
guys
strong companion so far
all right let's see we should probably
use a uh
let's use a sin just to see what's up
here
I might do a discussion on the direct
yeah that would that's a good good idea
there was so much information so many
games talked about and that Nintendo
Direct
which I thought Nintendo may have had
the best show out of the whole
the whole uh like lead up
Summer Games Fest E3 all that stuff you
know
PlayStation show was kind of
disappointing honestly Microsoft's was
solid
okay I think that one's gonna be
stronger so let's oh wait that one's
level five
let's see
is that the same bow
no that one's 11. all right so that was
that was a nice upgrade there
but yeah Nintendo they just had so many
good announcements I mean I guess if
you're not a big Mario fan then whoa no
wait wait wait we can fix this we can
fix this we can fix this
we just have to get on top of it first
we just have to no
no
oh my gosh we gotta hurry we gotta hurry
get up
that was messed up dude
okay wait before we rewind
on top of it
okay please take me back up
come on don't run out of time
no
dude that was messed up man
are they gonna fall back down again
oh my gosh
okay wait we can try it with this one
oh dude
it just it rolled so many times
okay okay
we gotta be like let's kind of Crouch
oh no no no no
come on come on come on we have to just
like
maneuver the right way no oh I don't
know what's happening
man come on fall back down
fall back down please
oh there it is there
oh my gosh we're gonna get this we are
gonna get this
okay come on
we're ready we're ready no we're not
ready we're not ready we're not ready
we're not ready
oh no it keeps
rolling so many times
eat something I know we should I'm just
I'm seeing if I can get this to go back
up first
come on come on come on come on come on
no link you gotta grab hold dude
hey wait
maybe we just need we just need to get
the position just right
please don't run out
we did it
oh my gosh
I did not want to have to climb all the
way back up there again
full recovery
nah I don't want to do full recovery I
want to do okay that would give me three
oh my gosh that was nerve-wracking you
guys
dude
is there a save point oh that that would
have been a good thing to try yeah to
see if if we would have um
if we like die and then jump back in
with that work would it bring us back up
there and dealing with the five uh Hey
thank you so much for the Super Chat
Dylan appreciate it all right let's eat
two of these toasted toasted hearty
truffles
that's crazy the uh
the stream elements chat bot is faster
than the alert above my head it tells me
first
whew we made it
that was
that was shaky to say the least man to
say the least
all right give us a nice little gust of
wind right there
dude that was that was closer than I
would like to see
okay let's get right under here
go through
exit
man
wait that's where we already were right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it is
I think we went the wrong way when we
got back up to the top here
yeah this is the way
yes that's where we fell right here
all right
it wasn't ready
I did not realize it wasn't ready yet
that was almost really bad
our flux Shield is really damaged
that's okay
this is the way indeed
oh dude we're so close
you know what Dylan what's funny is I
bet if we had died
oh my gosh that looks like a really
large bomb
if we had died it wouldn't have been a
problem it would have put us back up
there what is that thing
laughs
I guess we're about to find out if it
puts a speck up there
I guess we're about to find out
oh my gosh
let's see let's see yeah okay I was
right see if we had fell to our death
before it wouldn't have been a problem
but the fact that we survived it
it made it worse because then we were
stuck over there I'm gonna try something
different though this time I'm gonna go
over here
and I think we probably need to now
we're good on hearts
we're gonna go over here to the side
oh look at all these
okay so you can use ultra hand with them
all right what if we I want to see what
happens if I just shoot it with a normal
Arrow
okay they go over to investigate
oh my gosh it doesn't take them out
though
okay something else just exploded over
there oh what a shot
that guy would pinpoint accuracy over
there
pinpoint accuracy
oh my gosh it does so much damage toolin
how am I not dead
what is happening right how are we alive
did the game just glitch
hey buddy I don't know how I'm alive
you guys have fun
I mean I'm I'm it's not against other
people
[Music]
guys what just what just happened with
the Arts right there oh what the heck
[Music]
I'm not I'm not gonna complain
dude that was so weird
man we gotta find a way to destroy this
this was your favorite Temple steffe oh
my this is my first one and I'm not even
made it up here yet I've not even made
it we're still in route
all right what else do I have you guys
would anything else destroy these rocks
right here
hold on we do have
we do have these bombs
okay get away see if that will work
yeah it does okay nice
Jay-Z what's up welcome in
hey Timothy good to see you thank you
for stopping by
e the VOD will be up and ready if you
want to check in later
and we will post this over on the let's
play Channel as well it's just gonna be
like a edited down version of this here
all right let's see what kind of weapons
we got are we
honestly I don't I don't love what we're
rocking right now but
Rita how's it going Rita welcome
I still have no idea how we didn't die
right there like we got hit several
times and it was like our hearts just
stopped
the game just stopped showing us the
hearts like it didn't even matter
anymore
all right I see what they want us to do
at least I think I do
oh so the wood is gonna be lighter
I don't even know if we need to do that
I mean I guess we probably do
this might be too much though right is
this gonna be
these things are pretty powerful I I
feel like I remember them
oh man I also don't love like how much
space we've got to work here so let's do
this let's go ahead and bring
let's bring you on as well
see whenever you start adding more
plates like this though
then you have to worry about weight
distribution and all of that which
I guess we could just set up another one
we're gonna have a lot of uh Firepower
right here
let's see can we reach you
The Climb is such a journey I know it's
we've been going for hour and a half and
well we didn't I would say we've
probably been
probably about an hour like actually
doing the climb because we we kind of
had a little chatting and did some other
stuff first
all right
Also let's make sure that we're like
perfectly in position
because I think
it's gonna be too big of a problem to
reach that area right there
let's see
let's go
nice
love it when a plan comes together
so now we need to do a sin
Stefan I'm so far behind though I
haven't played in so long
hey Gabriella have a good one
thank you for stopping by and hanging
out appreciate it
okay
oh man we're getting close we're we're
so close
this might be it actually
nope not yet
not yet
all right I guess we're heading for the
big ice area over there
oh no I was looking away I was trying to
read chat
here let's just let's just hop sit right
here for a second you use wood to power
those before you figured out what the
flame Shooters did oh it burned through
no way
wait hold on and the fire what did you
say the fire
burned so long oh and it uses no battery
so wait it actually worked out
to your advantage
no you're you're dealing with a kidney
stone right now Steph a oh
I'm sorry to hear that
the air has become very cold you'll take
damage with your current outfits and
food effects oh great
okay
whoa I was trying to pause this is my
first time flying this High the air is
pretty cold up here huh
I'll be fine but what about you link
make sure you don't freeze okay
oh great
okay let's see if we have
anything to boost our cold okay first of
all let's check clothing
I think we're wearing the only thing
yeah this one right here
we're already wearing that
dude we've got so many meals but
oh we got plenty plenty plenty plenty
that's good
all right so let's do
we do need to heal some hearts anyway
that one does four minutes that's 840
but that doesn't heal any hearts right
there
let's do this one
you're like six and a half
six and a half should give us quite a
bit of time
right that's right Ruby on the shield
too yes we could also do that
oh this is big though you guys know why
this is big because now
if we fall or if something goes wrong
weak and fast travel back here
thankfully
all right let's see what this shrine's
got going on here
which would if we complete this Shrine I
think that will bring us up to
oh it was on screen and I just missed it
I think it'll bring us up to three
exactly Stephanie the Fast Travel oh
wait Rory's blessing nice it's one of
the easy ones let's go
large zonai charge
yeah I love these kinds this one was
basically just put here as a fast travel
point I feel like I feel like that was
its main purpose
all right light of blessing yep okay now
we're at three perfect need one more
and then I think our next one will fully
max out our second ring of stamina
because right now I'm pretty sure it's
about three-fourths of the way
yeah there it is you can see it in the
top right
so I think I want to go with one more
stamina and then I'm gonna focus on
hearts for a while after that
okay
oh dude this must be it right here
this might be it
no it's still not it
I don't know if this is the right way
but
this is where I'm going
this is where I'm going right here right
now
oh man this is so cool I love this
you guys are right the climb has been
really fun actually
yeah give me a little bit of extra just
to make sure we make it
I love that it resets your stamina right
there too when you do that
all right I'm gonna go this way I think
after all that climbing you've earned it
right I yeah I feel like that
that Shrine is definitely one you've
you've earned by the time you get up
there
oh that was that was a little uh a
little dangerously close right there all
right the good thing is there's a lot of
ships like I don't think I'm gonna be
able to yeah we might be able to make it
let's see
yep I'm totally glad I went for it
go for this one
no no
no it's all right it's all right there's
plenty up here
yeah I feel like you need to
kind of let go before you think you do
because it's moving faster than it looks
yeah look at that
oh here we go man come on
we gotta be gotta be close
oh we're in the heart of it right now
oh dude that was so cool look at that
man
look at how beautiful everything looks
launch us again
I don't know where we're supposed to go
now though
maybe like right into the middle of it
you think
that seems to be where the game is
leading us
all right I'm looking around I'm looking
around
I don't see anything else above us
yeah I guess do we go right into the
heart of it
oh my gosh dude
oh my gosh
that was epic
dude that was so epic getting up here
that moment right when you pop up above
the clouds incredible
[Music]
oh cutscene
wow so this is what was waiting for us
in that huge cloud
indeed
this is the Stormwind Arc from the kids
song
there she is
dude how is Zelda just appearing all
over the place like this man
how
what
this proves it link the blizzard that's
been pounding Rito Villages coming from
there
wind temple one F
oh my goodness we are officially here
and that is also officially the place
where we need to stop
good timing very good timing right there
Steve by the way thank you so much for
subscribing to the channel welcome in
peanut butter jelly oh dude that is a
great what a great YouTube name I love
it thank you so much for subscribing
guys if you're new and you haven't
subscribed here to the YouTube channel
yet make sure you subscribe uh we post
videos every week here on YouTube uh and
we're actually getting ready we're
getting ready to hop over to another
live stream here on YouTube with our
buddy uh expecto go
AKA well I know him as James but expect
to go
aka the Merlin conspiracy theorist
himself and we're going to be joined by
Andy reloads wizard PhD and Benjamin
snow so it's gonna be a lot of fun we're
gonna be hanging out for a little bit
talking games and I'm sure Hogwarts
Legacy will come up at some point I'm
sure Zelda will come up at some point
because I'm definitely talking about
that when it's my turn to talk about the
games that I've been enjoying playing
so yeah um we're gonna be over there
live in about 19 minutes so I'm gonna
hop off here now that way I can get in
the call with them a little bit early
and just make sure everything's set up
and ready to go so um oh wait hold on
Nick and Angie have I heard of the Star
Wars Outlaw game I did I saw the
announcement I haven't watched the
trailer yet I need to I need to watch
that we might do that on our live stream
one day
all right guys thank you all for being
here sorry to kind of ended abruptly
like this but I'm gonna take like a
quick bathroom break and then we'll be
right back live over on uh expecto ghost
channel so hope to see you there uh and
also if you guys are catching this later
in the VOD appreciate your support leave
a comment below replay Squad let me know
and as always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon
[Music]
foreign